korporal kira grünberg eine
leistungssportlerin des bundesheeres ist
beim training für den stabhochsprung
schwer verunglückt ihre vorgesetzten und
kameraden wollten im sinne der
kameradschaft unter solidarität etwas
für diese top athletin tun
oberst klein paul und andere
sportinteressierte haben die idee
geboren im rahmen der informations und
leistungsschau zum nationalfeiertag am
heldenplatz in wien einen 24-stunden
spendenlauf auf dem laufband für die
querschnittgelähmte stabhochspringerin
zu organisieren was kein paar selbst
wird versuchen in einem stück hat die 24
stunden durchzulaufen
sponsoren unterstützen den lauf als
hobbyläufer war es für mich
selbstverständlich habe ich möchte an
dieser stelle auch sagen dass ich mich
sehr darüber freue und mich bedanken
dass so viele sportlerinnen und sportler
auch heute sich hier beteiligen sich
ihrer selbst und besucht ich habe kehrer
besucht
ich muss dazu sagen es hat uns natürlich
alle erschüttert aber wie ich sie
kennengelernt habe sie ist eine mental
so starke persönlichkeit möchte ich auch
noch ein großes kompliment sagen diesem
zusammenhang
sie ist bei uns sozialrechtlich auch
abgesichert wir tun alles um ihr helfen
zu können
sie hat sich auch einen therapiehund
gewünschten den wunsch freue ich mich
dass wir auch erfüllen können
sie wird auch weiterhin bei uns beim
bundesheer bleiben wir werden sie
bestmöglich unterstützen
nachdem die kieler eine angehörige das
große sportlerin im herzzentrum ist und
dass aus dem kommando
einsatzunterstützung gehört ist es uns
klar gewesen dass wir alles tun wollen
ein zeichen setzen zu unterstützen nur
für sie da sein wollen
wie werden sie die 24 stunden überstehen
ich hoffe ich meine kleinen team wenn
man das durchkommen
es passt alles und boxte zum ersten mal
und es gibt harte phasen keine frage
aber deswegen müssen sie ist speziell
vorbereiten auf diesen tag
na ja schon man muss schon diese
einheiten setzen der körper trainieren
wir sind danach durch macht und durch
arbeitet dementsprechend auch den ersten
schon wichtig auch lange läuft werk so
und jetzt noch mitte einen glückwunsch
ankara ja wir sind nicht stolz mit
unterschied schon meistens in die hand
nimmst machen wir das so wir sind für
dich da vom 24 stunden ganz bei dir
jetzt was gut klar